in the lobby of Ramsay Solutions Kenneth
and Michelle are with us hey guys how
are ya good good welcome welcome it's
good to have you guys thanks for being
with us yeah appreciate you hanging out
where are you from
Omaha Omaha Nebraska and all the way to
Nashville to do your debt-free scream
correct
very cool good for you very neat so how
much have you paid off we've paid off
$90,000 I lied about 32 months good job
and your range of income during that
time high it started at 120 but it's
gone up - sorry starting at 110 and it
went up to 120 at the time we paid off
the house you paid off your house that's
correct
you guys aren't old enough to have a
paid-for house I know you're weird what
we do I love it congratulations very
nice what do y'all do for a living I
write code so I'm a web developer okay
cool and I'm a stay-at-home and
homeschool mom I love it good for you
very good so this debt the ninety
thousand was your house that's correct
Wow how old are you guys I am 36 and I'm
32 you have a paid-for house you know MA
Nebraska that's right what's the house
worth it's worth $300,000 yeah so what
happened 32 months ago that made you
decide to pay off your house well yeah
actually we started this journey back in
2008 mm-hm and then we paid off a house
about three years ago and then we took
out a mortgage of 90,000 to purchase the
$300,000 house and quickly got it paid
off in 32 months okay all right so you
moved up a little bit then knocked it
right out yes friend you knowing you
could do that because you've done it
before
easy yep very cool very good it's not
easy it's easy it's not easy it's easy
to understand what to do it's hard to do
it how many kids have y'all got
we've got you've got four it's hard to
do it okay I mean really yeah I mean
your home school mom there's two years
and after that it's it's pretty routine
yeah your home school mom's a magician
if they yeah she's doing good stuff
they're very fun well congratulations
what made you all be inspired to be out
of that one Michelle well we first took
it when we had just one baby and we had
some other debt at the time but not a
lot and once we got the our starter home
paid off and we knew we could do that we
were kind of you know we were in a great
place we went a year without having any
bills whatsoever and when we were
expecting our fourth we decided to go
ahead and move up in house because we
found just the perfect house for us in
the location and knew that that that
mortgage of 90 thousand that we could
get rid of it pretty quickly
so you took Financial Peace University
is that what you said yeah we took in
2008 oh okay and then I actually
facilitated the class four times oh wow
so thank you for leading very cool you
got quite a story to tell your class now
huh yeah you did the debt free scream
right here in the lobby and you actually
have no house payment yeah so when
somebody comes in there with their arms
all folded up you can't do this you're
gonna do this with your lip stuck out
you're like oh you can't can you do I
did it you know you can do it - very
cool very fun so what do you tell people
the secret to getting out of debt is
you've done it stop borrowing money
that's that's pretty simple that's good
that's a good first start step for sure
well I'm definitely having the same
goals and being on a team you know with
with being a single income family we
definitely he makes the money and I kind
of spend the money so I work we have to
be careful of you know budgeting and
making sure we're on the same page it's
also a lot of sacrifice in there as well
I've worked two jobs for the last eight
or nine years mm-hmm
so that's that can be pretty taxing
staying up late several nights a week
doing side projects mm-hmm but it's
worth it okay that's here you are I mean
you're 36 years old with the paid for
$3,000 house now $300,000 house in Omaha
Nebraska is no slouch that's a pretty
nice house it's big the four thousand
square foot house fits as well I love
how very cool well you should be a quick
well excellent excellent excellent job
so you brought the kiddos with you to
celebrate it and their names and ages
are what so Ryland is nine karena is
seven
violet is 5 and Shiloh turns 3 next week
all right very cool have they been
practicing their debt-free school they
have their debt free screaming
homeschool ok it's a homeschool lesson
right Wow I'm going to count it down
okay so we got a plan we hope so very
cool all right
90,000 dollars paid off in 32 months
making a hundred and twenty thousand a
year that's good that's well done got a
great debt free scream oh that's the
sound of a family being a tree being
changed right there that's mom and dad
made a decision to change everything and
the kids obviously know what's going on
and they're obviously part of the
program so they're sitting there very
very young or the paid for home you know
what you can do when you don't have a
mortgage payment anything you want you
just have to learn to think different
don't you well they've obviously learned
to do that Kenneth and Michelle
congratulations we're very proud of you
were going to give you a copy of Chris
Hogan's book retire inspired signed by
him cuz that's the next step for you
guys to continue to live like no one
else and later give like no one else hey
Kelly they're still standing there let's
bring them back up I think they didn't
like the kids scream but let's let them
do one more that's let's do a really
strong countdown because mom and dad
didn't get to scream on that one
let's let's do it again alright you want
to count it down count down
good yes she got an early one in there
so we want to make sure everybody got
involved good job you guys hey guys
thanks for watching if you enjoyed this
video click the subscribe button to get
the latest content and check out these
other great clips from the show you can
do this you know that really is a
message whether you've got two hundred
seventy thousand dollars in student loan
debt or twenty-seven thousand well
you've got a fifty thousand dollar
income or $500,000 in economy